hi there Steve here again 90 day
challenge Korean I'm just about halfway
through today I spent oh it must have
been an hour and a half reading on link
saving where's the phrases and then I
went to the office and I had a
discussion with Hammond in Korean we
went about eight minutes or so I will
probably put that up in a day or two
both Hanna and I again definitely
noticed my improvement over the last
time I haven't spoken for two weeks for
two weeks I've been reading and
listening with quite some difficulty to
these political podcasts and I think
that's significant because I always
stress the importance of listening and
reading obviously reading is to acquire
words and the listing is where you start
to develop the ability to produce the
language in my opinion but it's more
than that and and this is I'm gonna be a
little bit kind of I wouldn't left field
here as we say and that is that that
language obviously it's about
communicating it's about communicating
ideas but it's also about connecting
there is a theory that language
developed by our ancestors as a means of
sort of grooming each other you know we
humans we like to touch each other we
like to groom each other we like to feel
comfortable with each other we like to
feel that warmth of of human connection
and language enables us to do that and
every language has its own feel its own
flavor its own rhythm and I sensed that
today as I was driving to the office
listening to the Korean that I'm getting
closer to that world of Korean every
language every language has its world
whether it be Chinese or Russian or
Romanian or English or Korean and and to
penetrate that to get a feel for that
you have to listen and you have to read
reading is a form of listening I mean
after all before they have tape
recorders or any recording devices they
record it by writing down it it's a
recording of speech so you're actually
entering into that that's speed
that communication and you you have to
really to become a that's it to connect
with that language and events need to be
able to speak you have to put that
effort into trying to penetrate this
soft sticky idiosyncratic special taste
feel smell of the language and you do
that not by speed don't just jump in
there where you can't understand
anything and you just blurt out some
some words and look at me I can say a
few things that's not what it's about it
to my mind you first have to penetrate
that world and then having penetrated
and having feeling yourself a part of it
then the speaking becomes easier and
easier that's not to say that we
shouldn't speak whenever we have the
opportunity but it's again to emphasize
why I feel that putting you know the
production of the language or correct
even worse correct production of the
language up front rather than this sense
of absorbing the language of
assimilating and getting a sense for
getting a feel for getting comprehension
that that's what should be upfront not
the idea of what I can do in the
language and so I really felt that today
and I really feel again that with every
day I'm getting closer to that feeling
that I'm participating in the Korean
language world and that's gonna an inch
eventually enable me to speak better and
better so a little bit esoteric today
but not just thought I'd share those
thoughts with you bye for now